democrats succeed in a vote to uphold
the constitutionality of impeaching
president trump after he has left office
democrats pushed the case that trump
incited violence but try to avoid
culpability for their own violent
rhetoric
and the biden administration continues
to push radical policy under the radar
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben will get to all of the news in just
a moment because we are at the beginning
of the senate conviction trial for
president trump over impeachment
day two so we'll get to that in just one
moment first there has never been a more
important time to protect your internet
activity than right this moment that is
why i urge you to get express
vpn the reality is there are a lot of
folks out there who would love your
internet data i'm not just talking about
hackers
i'm talking about folks in big tech who
you don't trust with any of your
information but they have all your
information anyway
well everything you search for watch or
click online can be tracked by big tech
companies they can then match your
activity to your true identity
using your device's unique ip address
when i switch on expressvpn with my
computer or phone
my ip address is masked by a secure vpn
server which makes it harder for
websites to identify me
the expressvpn app also encrypts my
network data to protect my sensitive
information from being compromised plus
you can use expressvpn on up to five
devices simultaneously so multiple users
on your network can stay safe with a
single subscription
what i like most is how easy it is to
use it takes just one click to protect
all of your devices there's a reason
they're rated the number one vpn by both
cnet and wired
it's always important to protect your
important stuff while your data is
some of the most important stuff you
have why would you not protect it from
prying eyes
stop handing over your data to big tech
companies head on over to vpni trust for
online protection visit expressvpn.com
ben to get three months free on a
one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
ben to get three extra months for free
go to expressvpn.com right now to learn
more okay
so yesterday a vote was held
in the day one of the the senate
conviction trial for president trump's
impeachment the senate decided to
proceed with the trial
um basically there was a vote held last
week it showed that 55 to 45 the senate
believed it was constitutional to hold
an impeachment trial a conviction trial
for trump after he had left office
this was sort of an open constitutional
question because certainly it's never
been used against a president
this way the constitutional case in
favor of the constitutionality
of trump being tried after leaving
office is that the punishment is not
merely being kicked from office it is
also being barred from
future office not only that but he was
actually impeached while he was in
office he's now being
tried for conviction after he leaves
office that's the constitutional case in
short
in favor of the constitutionality the
constitutional case against
is he's already out of office so what
exactly are you removing him from
there's nothing to remove him from
plus when it comes to how this
particular process has been run
the supreme court chief justice is
supposed to preside over the process
here you don't have that here you have
pat leahy from vermont who's actually
presiding over a trial in which he is
going to vote
the the republicans are claiming that
this is unfair bottom line is this
they took a vote on this last week they
took another vote on it yesterday
these democrats certainly had enough of
a vote majority
to push forward with the actual trial it
was 55 45 last week
last night it was 56 to 44. senator bill
cassidy from louisiana switched
his vote so this was the the content
of the trial yesterday the content was
can we even go forward
with the trial the 44 republicans who
agreed with trump's claim
a former president cannot be subjected
to an impeachment trial seemed to all
but seem to all but guarantee he would
have the 34 votes he needs on the final
verdict to avoid conviction according to
the new york times to succeed the house
managers would need to persuade at least
11 republican senators to find
trump guilty in a trial they have deemed
unconstitutional so look it's a fate
accompli he's not getting convicted in
the senate we all know this democrats
know this the republicans
know this that puts to the side the
question of whether he should be
convicted
in my opinion the answer is no the
reason being that the standard that is
laid out in the impeachment article
is not a neutral standard that can be
applied across the aisle if you are
going to say
that he is responsible for incitement as
we're going to get to in just a moment
you're also going to have to say that
reckless rhetoric by a variety of
politicians
which results in action that was
unforeseeable
is going to be attributable to them and
therefore they also can be kicked out of
the chamber that's going to hit a lot of
members of congress a lot of senators
and a lot of future and past presidents
by the way so in any case
the arguments were laid out yesterday
trump's lawyers did not do a good job by
virtually all accounts trump's lawyers
were pretty bad
uh there was a fellow named caster bill
caster who was one of trump's lawyers
and he was not particularly good jamie
raskin
was given wide plaudits for his
presentation of the
of the pro-trial argument and jamie
raskin
uh is of course a representative from
maryland he said if we don't impeach
trump that would create a january
exception to the constitution the case
he's making constitutionally
is that basically what you're saying is
if you can't impeach him
after he's left office then let's say
the president does something super duper
duper duper corrupt
on january 15th well i mean now you're
basically making the case the president
can do whatever he wants
so long as it is close enough to him
leaving office now that does leave aside
a couple of
of major issues one is that that
kind of is true already for second-term
presidents
right if you are if you are a
second-term president then you being
convicted
after having been impeached after
leaving office makes no difference you
are legally barred by law from running
for presidents of the united states
again
so if barack obama were to be impeached
and convicted now
there would be no actual penalty that
attaches because he's not actually
legally allowed to run for president
again so for second-term presidents it
already exists
this sort of january exception that
raskin is talking about
but the broader argument is not a
terrible one which is that you don't
actually want to create a feeling
that the the president of the united
states can do whatever he wants in the
final month without having to worry
about any consequence whatsoever
from congress what it does suggest that
the proper measure here would have been
censure which is something that i had
suggested
months ago kevin mccarthy had suggested
it months ago that democrats turned it
down flat
because of course they wish to force
republicans to the mat the idea here is
they want republicans to vote
for trump's impeachment and conviction
and nothing else they don't want the
opportunity for republicans to distance
themselves from trump's actions without
also voting for impeachment here is
jamie raskin
making the case yesterday this would
create
a brand new january exception
to the constitution of the united states
of america a january exception
and everyone can see immediately why
this is so dangerous
it's an invitation to the president to
take his best
shot at anything he may want to do
on his way out the door including using
violent
means to lock that door to hang on to
the oval office
at all costs okay so a couple of things
okay so
so now he's making a case that he has
not yet made right that's the case that
they're going to try and make today
which is that trump tried to violently
overthrow the united states government
which is not true
okay but let's talk for a second about
this so-called january exception
okay the reality is that presidents do
bad crap on the way out all the time
bill clinton pardoned a bunch of his
political allies on the way out of
office this is very very common
barack obama did a bunch of terrible
political stuff on his way out of office
up to and including his administration
monitoring the incoming trump
administration and sticking law
enforcement on them without any sort of
cause
and so it turns out the presidents
fairly often do this sort of thing where
on the way out the door
they do a bunch of stuff that they knew
they couldn't get away with if they were
still two years left in their terms
that's not a particularly strong
argument however bruce castor is the
name of trump's attorney he did not make
a particularly compelling case yesterday
he was trying to make the case that the
impeachment was unconstitutional
even trump himself was apparently very
angry with bruce castor's performance
yesterday virtually every republican
senator was like i don't know where you
picked this guy up
i don't know if he was like a personal
injury attorney in dubuque and he sort
of grabbed him
off the line and decided to throw him up
there an impeachment trial but he did
not receive plot it's not not a lot of
great reviews for bruce castro yesterday
if we go down the road that my
very worthy adversary here mr raskin
asks you to go down the floodgates will
open the political pendulum will
shift one day
this chamber and the chamber across the
way
will change one day
and partisan impeachments will become
commonplace okay so he's not wrong about
that part
right the idea that there's gonna be
partisan impeachments all the way down
he's
he's not wrong about that once you open
the door to repeatedly impeaching a guy
over and over and over
that does set a precedent caster said we
this was the most awkward moment
he he sort of said jamie raskin is doing
an unbelievably good job here and um and
we have responses to that stuff but
we'll get to that later it's like okay
well you know you didn't need to do that
that was that was not useful here was
bruce castro yesterday
i'll be quite frank with you we changed
what we were going to do on account that
we thought that the house manager's
presentation
was well done and i wanted you to know
that we have responses to those things
we have counter arguments to everything
that they raised
and you will hear them later on in the
case from mr van der veen
and from myself so um not great not
great bob
meanwhile trump's other attorney got him
david chain he played tape of democrats
calling for impeachment since the very
first days and this is a better case
right he's saying
that when it comes to the
constitutionality of impeaching trump
that is one thing when it comes to the
politics of impeaching trump but it's
pretty obvious that democrats believe
that trump's illegitimate they've been
after him since
day one it was amazing to watch the
media the clown themselves by the way
just a quick side note it's an orthodox
jew the media absolutely many in the
media be clowned themselves yesterday
because shane is an orthodox jew
and there was one point where he took a
swig of water and he took a swig of
water he put his hand on his head
and a bunch of people in the media were
like well that's funny he put his hand
on his head it was he leaked
essie cup from cnn does he have a leak
up there no that's not how that works
just so folks know i wear a yamaka well
the reason the jews wear yamako orthodox
jews wear yamaka
is because you're supposed to cover your
head when you make a blessing you're
supposed to make a blessing every time
you have food or drink
he was not wearing a yamaka so this
happens fairly frequently if you're not
wearing a yamaka you've forgotten to put
one on or you're not wearing one
and you want to make a blessing you put
your hand over your head in lieu of
yamaka that's what was going on
yesterday in any case
side point but our culturally sensitive
media ever ever
culturally sensitive uh they went nuts
over that and then
later had to walk that back in any case
shane played tape of democrats calling
for impeachment since the very first
days and this of course is true
who i may well be voting to impeach
donald trump has already done a number
of things
which legitimately raised the question
of impeachment i don't respect this
president
and i will fight every day
until he is impeached that is grounds to
start impeachment proceedings those are
grounds to start
impeachment those are grounds to start
impeachment proceedings yes i think
that's grounds to start impeachment
proceeding
i rise today mr speaker
to call for the impeachment
of the president of the united states of
america
so um yes i mean that happens to be
right from trump's attorney's team which
is
okay you guys keep saying that he did
something impeachable but you've been
saying he's been doing impeachable stuff
since literally the day he arrived on
the scene
so take everything that you say with a
grain of salt that said was the case
particularly compelling on a
constitutional level not particularly
bill cassidy the senator from louisiana
he voted he switched his vote since last
week he said listen trump's legal team
did a really crappy job on this
particular issue now that doesn't mean
cassidy's voting for impeachment
it means that he's voting in favor of
the idea that it is constitutional to
impeach
frankly i tend to agree that it is
constitutional to impeach a president
after he has left office that doesn't
mean i think that it should be done in
this case but as far as the actual legal
constitutionality of the thing
i think there's a fairly strong case
fairly strong argument uh that it is
constitutional to do that sort of thing
after somebody has left office so
and that if that is the standard that we
are now going to apply then i look
forward to applying it
into the future here is uh here's bill
cassidy making the case
yesterday it was disorganized
random had nothing they talked about
many things but they didn't talk about
the issue at hand
and so if i if you if i'm an impartial
juror
and i'm trying to make a decision based
upon
the facts as presented on this issue
then the house managers did a much
better job
the issue at hand is is it
constitutional to impeach
a president who's left office and the
house managers
made a compelling cogent case
and the president's team did not
alrighty so bottom line though is that
it passes but
it doesn't pass with like flying colors
the six senators who voted in favor of
the constitutionality were the five
from last week plus cassidy that is not
gonna be nearly enough to get democrats
across the finish line on actually
convicting trump
in the senate in just a second we're
going to get to what exactly is going to
happen today
in the impeachment trial what is
happening today in the impeachment trial
in the senate first
let us talk about the best clothing
available it is 2021 the year of the
rally as we kick 2020 into the rearview
mirror
it's time we start dressing for the
occasion and for the man that's always
on and there's cuts of clothing let me
just tell you
their stuff is fantastic i wear cuts
clothing literally every day they've
taken a classic men's fashion staple the
plain tee they've refined it combining
premium quality with minimalist
aesthetic
cuts shirts pillows hoodies crew
sweatshirts they're made for the man who
works hard plays hard and doesn't settle
for less all
in the sport of business they're built
for performance in the boardroom at the
bar or the gym
cuts clothing keeps you sharp wherever
the game takes you take a plain tee but
make it tony stark
the bleeding edge of fabric technology
meets the man confident enough to wear
it that is cut
clothing the shop-by-cut experience
gives you the power to choose your
signature t-shirt you can select your
collar
bottom cut color each cut is tailored to
fit your lifestyle they're sophisticated
they're presentable for the workplace
they're stylish for a night on the town
i seriously wear cuts literally every
day and when i say every day i mean like
i've thrown out pretty much
all of my other t-shirts because cuts is
just that good they have fantastic polo
shirts they have excellent
they have excellent long tees just their
product is fantastic it is comfortable
it is durable and it looks great
entrepreneurs mavericks athletes podcast
hosts everybody loves cuts clothing
their echoing gq is the only shirt worth
wearing kick off 2021 the right way
starting with your wardrobe get 15
off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com
shapiro that is cuts clothing dot com
shapiro for 15
off the only shirt worth wearing okay so
now we get beyond the sort of
procedurals here and we get to the
actual content of
the impeachment trial now let's be frank
about what this is all about what this
is really all about for democrats
is political gamesmanship the new york
times essentially admitted
as much today when they acknowledge that
basically
democrats have a win-win scenario either
trump
is convicted in which case they get a
big victory not going to happen or trump
is not convicted in which case they've
had a chance for a couple of weeks to
beat up on republicans and in the future
they get to
to tie republicans in pr fashion to what
happened on january 6th so they think
well
there is one possibility that this
backfires and that is the longer that it
goes on the less the american people
seem to love it so here is what the
polls show right now according to the
new york times a majority of americans
support convicting trump
on an impeachment charge over his role
in the capital ride on january 6th
only by a very slender margin according
to a range of recent polls
while there's broad agreement trump
deserves at least some blame for the
violence at the capitol the country
remains more closely split over whether
he deserves to be convicted by the
senate
in fact the views around this
impeachment trial aren't very different
from how things looked a year ago when
public opinion was tilted slightly in
favor of removing trump from office
during his first
impeachment trial democrats have since
gained control of the senate but they
need a bunch of republicans to vote with
them
basically the split is 5644 in a cbs
news at yougov poll
56 percent of americans saying that
trump should be convicted 44 saying
he should be acquitted but there are
other polls that are way narrower
there's 12 percent of americans who said
they have no opinion on this and only 47
percent of americans saying they're in
favor of the impeachment 40
opposed according to the ap a cue polk
quinnipiac university
found last week that 50 of americans
said the senate should convict trump 45
said that it should not okay so bottom
line is that americans
seem to be pretty split on this
particular issue
uh and as time goes on and as it becomes
apparent
that trump is no longer in office and as
congress continues to
basically just posture i think more and
more americans are going to say this is
kind of a waste of time that's the
reason why chuck schumer is rushing this
thing forward
he had an interest in getting this thing
done fast right he wants a quick strike
pr hit
gets to use this for the rest of time to
smear the republican party with
that is his goal here then of course he
says he's doing this in the name of
unity which of course is very very silly
here is chuck schumer
the the democratic senate majority
leader saying that um you know we can't
move on because
that's not going to bring unity yes
apparently only unity can be achieved
by trying to lump every republican in
with the january 6th rioters which is
really what
from a pr level from a comms level
communications level that's what this
trial is really all about it's not about
trump
trump is a background figure almost in
this trial at this point here's chuck
schumer
saying hypocritically that it's not
going to bring unity to move beyond the
trial listen
i don't think that unity is the highest
value i really don't
but if your case is that in order for us
to achieve unity
we have to push forward with an
impeachment that half the country
doesn't support that's a weird way to
achieve unity
here is a here is chuck schumer those
who say let's move on
that brings unity are false when you had
such a serious
invasion of the capital
incited by
a president when you have such a serious
charge
sweeping it under the rug will not bring
unity it will keep the sore
open and the wounds open
okay so here is my favorite part of the
the constitutional argument being made
by democrats
so one of the things they are now
considering is blatantly
unconstitutional
if the impeachment trial fails one of
the things that they are currently
considering is the possibility of
invoking the 14th amendment
which could be done by pure majority
vote to bar trump from running for
office
ever again section 3 of the 14th
amendment allows congress to bar
individuals from holding office if they
have quote unquote engaged in
insurrection they included that in the
impeachment charge itself
but trump did not quote unquote engage
in insurrection he left office as
provided by law on january 20th
with no sort of official support
to bar him from office at this point
would be pretty obviously a
constitutional bill of attenders as ed
morrissey writes over at hot air
nothing in the language of the 14th
amendment confers authority on congress
to do anything except
waive a particular prohibition it
prohibits people who have committed
certain crimes from holding federal
office
nothing in this denies these people from
having due process in a court of law to
make that determination of guilt
in the first place because the fact of
the matter remains that you have to have
due process of law in order to
punish somebody this way congress is not
a court in any mode
other than impeachment democrats know it
by the way
right the fact is democrats know this
but they don't really care right
steve cohen is a democrat from tennessee
and he said
i know there's some concern about being
a bill of attender i'm not concerned
about that because what he did was
horrific
and this is the way the democrats tend
to think i don't really care about the
constitutionality argument so
two things can be true once as very
often is true it can be constitutional
to hold an impeachment trial after a
person has left office
also the people who are arguing that
cannot care very much about the
constitution
that can certainly be a possibility okay
in just a second we're gonna get to
the actual argument being made by
democrats and that is the incitement
argument we'll get to why that falls
short as well in just one second first
let's be real it is a short month
february is a short month and we have
already passed january
you need to get life insurance okay the
reality is if you want to knock that off
your to-do list there's a very easy and
quick way to do it
it can be done at policygenius.com
policy genius can help you check off two
big items with ease you can compare life
insurance rates and say 50
or more in the process that means more
cash you put toward the things you care
about
whatever that may be plus there's no
hassle their license experts work for
you
not the insurance companies so they can
offer unbiased advice when you need it
here's how it works first you head on
over to policygenius.com in minutes you
can work out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price
policy genius will then compare policies
starting at as little as a buck a day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape if you
hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across over 1
600 reviews on trustpilot
and google if you are worried about the
people that you care about in case god
forbid something happens
you need life insurance which means if
you're a responsible human you should
have life insurance
policy genius can make that happen for
you you could say 50 or more by
comparing quotes
feel good knowing your loved ones would
be taken care of if anything were to
happen go to policygenius.com to get
started again that is policygenius.com
alrighty so the democrats actually
started laying out
their impeachment case yesterday and not
just the constitutional case the
impeachment case
that's really what trump's lawyer was
was referring to earlier caster was
referring to the idea that
i thought this trial was supposed to be
separated into the constitutional
argument and then the content argument
democrats let off right
democrats know this is a pr ploy
basically so they led off the bat
with this 13-minute video that was
effectively edited
that that showed trump speaking and
juxtaposed it with footage
from the capitol riot here's a little
bit of what that sounded like
we're gonna walk down we're gonna walk
down
to the capitol
[Music]
[Applause]
fight like hell and if you don't fight
like hell you're not going to have a
country anymore
okay well there's only one problem with
this particular video and again the
juxtaposition is ugly what happened on
january 6th was really really ugly but
the democrats have to make the argument
that trump foreseeably incited a riot at
the capitol building
an unprecedented event in american
history right so here's the thing with
things being unprecedented
usually they're not super foreseeable
the part of this that made it
foreseeable in fact was the fact that
the fbi apparently was keeping tabs on
people who were openly talking about
storming
the capitol building in days prior which
means the january 6th events weren't the
spurring event you can make the argument
that trump's overall argument
was ginning people up that's true but
you cannot make the argument i think
in in all good conscience that trump's
january sixth speech itself
incited the riot i mean the man did say
peacefully and patriotically march to
the to the capitol building right that
is what he said
okay i have to say this is pretty
amazing newsweek fact check this it just
shows you again how corrupt the fact
checkers are
they did a fact check did trump say to
peacefully and patriotically march to
the capitol
fact check mostly true mostly true
that's literally a direct quote of what
he said
okay but that never appeared in that
democratic video instead they just
showed trump saying fight like hell and
all this i mean that is typical
ramped up political rhetoric democrats
have said that sort of stuff from time
immemorial so republicans
fighting politically is not the same
thing as go invade the capitol building
and hit a bunch of police officers with
polls that is not the same thing
in any way shape or form so basically
what democrats are attempting to do at
this point
is simply ramp up the emotional rhetoric
that makes sense again for a pr trial
which this basically is david sicily
a democrat i believe he's from louisiana
he was saying that january 6
was a national tragedy and trump incited
it this is their argument
this was a national tragedy
a disaster for america standing in the
world
and president trump is singularly
responsible for inciting it
as we will prove the attack on the
capital was not solely the work of
extremists lurking in the shadows indeed
does
anyone in this chamber honestly believe
that but for the conduct of president
trump
that that a charge in the article of
impeachment that that attack at the
capitol would have occurred
does anybody believe that okay so here
is the thing the standard that sicilian
is using right there he says does anyone
believe that but for
trump's activity that wouldn't have
occurred the butt force standard of
causation is very rarely used in law
okay because the reality is but for many
things this wouldn't have occurred right
but for trump losing the election this
wouldn't have occurred
but for universal mail and balloting
this wouldn't have occurred are those
things responsible for the riot no
the answer of course is no so democrats
are really not making a legal case
they're really not making even a
particularly convincing
i would say political case but they are
making an emotionally laden one
and that of course is the entire point
here we'll get some more of this in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that now is a terrible time to go
to the post office post office a great
place but you don't want to be waiting
in line at the post office with a bunch
of packages that you need to send
instead
you want to save time you want to save
money you want to do all of this from
your home or office
that is what stamps.com exists to do you
should mail and ship online using
stamps.com stamps.com allows you
to mail and chip anytime anywhere right
from your computer you can send letters
ship packages pay a lot less with
discounted rates from usps ups
and more stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
with stamps.com
you get the services of the post office
and ups all in one place plus you get
big discounts on mailing and shipping
rates
here at dailywire we've been using
stamps.com since 2017. we won't waste
our time we won't waste our money that
is why we are a highly profitable
company at least in part to decisions
like using
stamps.com stamps.com brings the
services of usps and ups directly
to your computer you can use your
computer to print official us postage 24
7 for any letter
any package any class mail anywhere you
want to send it and you get discounts up
to 40 percent
off post office rates up to 62 off ups
shipping rates
stop wasting time going to the post
office go to stamps.com instead there's
no risk with my promo code shapiro you
get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale no long-term commitments
no contracts just head on over to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in shapiro again that
is stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office
again okay so the case that is being
made by democrats over and over and over
again
is that it is trump's violent rhetoric
that drove what happened
on january 6th that he is responsible
for incitement
right that is the argument that that
continually is made here and the media
of course are backing
this one to the hilt and the media love
this argument
so cnn sanderson cooper from a network
that routinely made excuses for violence
during the actual
black lives matter riots of the summer i
had people like chris cuomo getting on
air and talking about how it was just
like the boston tea party to burn down
your local walmart
hey anderson cooper is like you know
trump supporters can't claim they love
law order well what if i hate what
happened on january 6th
can i still claim i love law order
because i do hate what happened on
january 6th
i thought that it was an act of evil but
apparently according to anderson cooper
unless you are willing to say that trump
is responsible
for incitement of the riot and people
are deprived of their agency and him
saying peacefully and patriotically
march on the capitol
and then a riot ensuing that those two
things are
so directly linked that he must be
impeached if you're unwilling to vote
how i understand cooper wants you to
vote in other words this means you can't
say you love law and order anymore
the former president united states
cannot claim to be a law and order
president when you have the crowds
chanting killed the blue you saw the
hurling insults and fists and objects
and the american flag and a hockey stick
at officers as you said gouging out an
eye but officer lost three fingers and
you know one officer was killed two
others have died by suicide
uh any claim by them that that they are
lovers of law and order
it rings hollow certainly after after
seeing that
okay who is they who is they is it is it
like everybody who doesn't
the 44 of americans 40 of americans who
think that trump
is not directly responsible for what
happened during the january sixth
capital act which again were
unprecedented in american history when
everybody watched with their draw to the
floor it's because that hasn't happened
before
so saying that this was completely
foreseeable by trump is a stretch
it is also true that you see from the
democrats over and over they keep saying
new evidence is going to drop and it's
going to show you just how just how
involved the white house was
okay anytime seriously this is an
impeachment trial any time
they've been saying for weeks the
republican members of congress were
complicit in the attack
they've been saying that members of
congress were scoping the hallways for
the capital rioters
i mean alexander ocasio-cortez accused
ted cruz of being an accomplice to
attempted murder
like any time you guys want to show this
evidence would be fan freaking-tastic
because you know what convinces me not
your ramped-up rhetoric what convinces
me actually
is the evidence so let's see the
evidence if trump was planning
the january sixth riot then let's see it
and him him tweeting out that it's gonna
get wild on january 6th
okay everybody tweets that it's gonna
like seriously a lot of people tweet
things like it's going to get wild at my
rally
they don't mean that we are going to go
storm the capitol building and attack
police officers
as a general rule and when it comes to
trump's tweets and him tweeting
wild things we're supposed to believe
that that is what is directly
responsible for a bunch of
nuts and and evil people storming the
capital building of the united states
but again this is this is the goal here
and the standard that is being used here
essentially is if a bad thing happened
and it did and the people who did the
bad thing credit trump
then we have to take them super duper
seriously this is what philip bump at
the washington post is arguing quote
over and over and over arrested rioters
say what spurred them trump
and philip bump says it's been a month
since an armed mob stormed the us
capital to try to prevent congress from
counting the electoral votes cast after
the 2020 presidential election
the righteous mob was largely made up of
supporters of president donald trump
who called on his base to come to
washington on january 6th for a wild
protest of election results he'd spent
months trying to discredit
that morning he encouraged those who had
made the trip to fight for their country
and to march for the capital
they did it's worth putting a fine point
on two things the first
is that the effects of the day's
violence are still tangible second its
proximate clause is no less murky
hours before the impeachment trial began
in the senate on tuesday federal law
enforcement officers in georgia arrested
benjamin torrey one of those accused of
breaching the capital that day
like so many others who have already
been arrested tori left a wide trail on
social media
pointing to his participation in the
day's events tori's only the most recent
person
to be arrested but he may not be by the
time you read this nearly every day
since january 6th
law enforcement officials have arrested
someone allegedly involved in storming
the capital by the way this is a quick
note
the entire media ran with the blatantly
stupid line
that law enforcement was biased against
black people because they weren't
arresting people for the capital riot
they've been arresting people every
single day for the capital right they
were understaffed at the time which was
the entire problem
okay but says phillip bump over at the
washington post
from those who have already been
arrested we hear a consistent refrain
they were there to support trump or in
their view
there at his behest okay so um i have a
question
the the congressional baseball shooter
literally quoted bernie sanders while
shooting people
if he said i'm here because i believe
this is what bernie would have wanted me
to do
does that mean that we would have to
charge bernie sanders with incitement
or see him as an accomplice to attempted
murder i don't think so during the black
lives matter riots if you had asked
black lives matter rioters why you were
doing this they would articulate the
exact same arguments made
by people like hannah nicole hannah
jones over the new york times
who by the way tweeted that she was very
excited that people were calling
the riots the 1619 riots say is she
responsible for i don't think she's
responsible for the riots
i think she's responsible for all the
stupid crap that comes out of her mouth
and pen but i don't think that
she is responsible for the riots using
the argument that people who committed
criminal acts
cite this person as the inspiration for
those criminal acts does not mean
that a rational mind would say that the
activity
of politically ramping up the rhetoric
politically
being inflammatory the way that trump
often is or even politically saying
things that are not true as i think
trump was doing during the election
during the post-election cycle that that
is responsible for people doing
something unprecedented
in american history and here's the thing
here's the thing people on the left know
this
they know this right this is why they
are very much afraid of the argument
that is being made by people on the
right
which is you guys you use rhetoric like
this all the time
so to take an example jimmy kimmel right
obviously a supporter
of conviction impeachment and uh and
using and loading trump onto a trebuchet
and launching him into space
jimmy kimmel you know our great moral
arbiter pope kimmel over here
he says that um you know when trump was
using this sort of language then he
should have known
that there were people who would have
gone and done this because you can't
expect people
to understand hyperbole here was jimmy
kimmel
his lawyers are saying he's not
responsible
because people should have known he was
using hyperbole when he told them to
fight like hell
and then they ran down the street did
you get like the guy in the viking
costume
and the lady with the words camp
auschwitz printed on her
triple xl sweatshirt should know what
hyperbole is okay but that's the entire
point now you're making
my point so we are going to judge
whether somebody was using hyperbole or
not
by nut cases that's how we're going to
judge this
so when bernie sanders i cite this case
because this was a case where people
were actually shot and somebody was
nearly murdered
because that's a case where actual
violence ensued if that shooter
was shouting this is for healthcare
right after bernie sanders had suggested
repeatedly and openly the republicans
healthcare plan was for you to die
would jimmy kimmel be say and when i
mean that is a hyperbolic statement is
it not the republicans health care plan
was for you to die
that was not that was not a true
statement it's hyperbole the vast
majority of rational human beings
understand that that is political
hyperbole
but according to jimmy kimmel's argument
we can now say
that bernie sanders should have known
that would impact nut cases
in such a way that they would probably
go and shoot other fellow members of
congress
that's not the way any of this works we
don't judge whether rhetoric is
responsible for activity
by taking people who are the nuttiest
among us and then saying well we should
have known that those nuts were going to
go do something terrible
if we use the nuttiest and their
behavior as the standard for what we can
and cannot say
there's gonna be very little we can and
cannot say because it turns out that
people who do evil crazy things
very often do not need an excuse to do
evil or crazy things and or
misinterpret things on a regular basis
because they are evil and crazy
so jimmy kimmel knows this you know who
else knows this yamiche alcindor over at
pbs so yamiche alcindor who is not a
journalist right she's a
pseudo-journalist she's an activist
she says you know when republicans cite
rhetoric from like maxine waters and
kamala harris
you know there wasn't a storming of the
capital after maxine waters and kamala
harris spoke
here she was making this case the trump
team as we as you've reported
um also is going to be bringing out this
video trying to say hear what democrats
said
here's why they're just like president
trump but i think the the thing that's
going to be so obvious is going to be
that there wasn't
a storming of the capital after maxine
waters or or
senator harris then senator harris had
fiery speeches um
except that senator harris literally
tweeted out support for rioters in the
middle of the riot
senator harris tweeted out a link to a
bail fund
for people who'd been arresting for
looting looting and rioting in
minneapolis
so uh yeah that that does have something
to do with the violence in fact it has
more directly to do with the violence
than what trump said
on january 6th so democrats know that
this argument is not a winning argument
they just understand that if they show
the video of january 6th over and over
and over again
that people are justifiably upset about
january 6th and they hope to link all
republicans to it that is the purpose of
this entire
exercise that's the purpose of this
entire exercise they tried to do this
yesterday
with mike lee and full disclosure
senator lee is uh is a friend of mine
i think that he's maybe the most honest
guy in congress uh and and he was making
the case that when it comes to democrats
he's not even talking about trump here
he says democrats say inflammatory stuff
all the time
and we don't we don't pretend that the
inflammatory rhetoric
used by democrats is responsible for
incitement everybody gets a mulligan
right that's what he was saying he was
talking about democrats the media
immediately took this and suggested that
what he meant
is that trump should get a mulligan for
his rhetoric which is not what we were
saying in the first place in any case
here was
senator lee these are
outgrowths of the same natural impulse
uh
that exist from time to time among
anyone in this business and in many
other businesses
look everyone makes mistakes everyone's
entitled to a mulligan
once in a while and i would hope i would
expect that each of those individuals
would take a mulligan
on each of those statements because in
each instance
they're making it deeply personal
they're they're ceasing to make it about
policy instead they're talking about
getting up in people's faces and making
individuals feel perfectly uh uh
uncomfortable and that's not helpful
okay so there he's explicitly
referencing maxine waters and alexander
ocasio-cortez
and that's what's he and he's giving the
standard that i think most rational
people give
which is people use inflammatory
rhetoric in politics all the time it is
bad
it does not mean that you're responsible
for incitement necessary that you should
be removed from office
here's the thing the biden
administration knows this too right jen
sackey was specifically asked whether
democrats using incendiary rhetoric was
different from trump
and she dodged the question of course
the former president's
lawyers argue based on the briefs that
they have filed
that some democrats have used incendiary
rhetoric how does the white house view
that
as any difference look the president is
joe biden is the president he's not a
pundit he's not going to opine on
the back and forth arguments nor is he
watching them that are taking place
uh in the senate so yeah we're going to
skip right over that one which um
which makes perfect sense right of
course they're going to skip over that
one because that is not an argument that
democrats even want to deal with
there were widespread riots that
resulted in 2 billion dollars in damage
the most damaging riots in american
history
okay and they happened this summer and
there were democrats actively cheering
it on
okay they don't want this argument this
is why they tried to disappear it off
the front pages in real time this is why
they lied to you in the media
suggesting that these were quote unquote
mostly peaceful protests
they were mostly peaceful in the sense
that the vast majority of protests did
not result in massive property damage
but there that is no standard for
whether a movement is peaceful or not
most of the stuff lots of movements do
is peaceful and then there's another
part where they're not so peaceful
but democrats don't want to talk about
any of that because then of course we
get into very uncomfortable territory so
understand what this impeachment trial
is and what it is not it is really not
for the vast majority there are some
members of congress who i think are
honestly trying
to determine whether trump did something
impeachable and then there are democrats
who are really
just attempting to make political hay
out of
one of the most vile events in american
politics of my lifetime on january 6th
and i'm not talking about trump's speech
i'm talking about the actual storming of
the capitol building and by the way the
reaction to that has also been
extraordinarily bad i mean the reaction
which is lock down dc under essentially
military occupation all the way until
march and spend half a million half a
billion dollars doing it
the reaction which is knock parlor off
the internet and tell all the social
media companies to clamp down
on traffic to sites that you don't like
the reaction which is free speech itself
should be put under attack
that is that does no credit to democrats
at all
it's it's pretty astonishing stuff in
fact okay in just a second we're gonna
get to the stuff that's actually
happening in politics that matters you
know like the policy that's happening
while everybody is distracted over here
with the impeachment trial that makes no
difference because trump's been out of
office
and uh they're not going to convict him
nor are they going to ban him from
running in the future
nor by the way have i seen him have any
inclination to run in the future at this
point
there's actual stuff going on with the
other hand okay we're gonna get to that
in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that i have
three children they wake me up at all
hours of the night they woke me up
before six o'clock
am this morning as per our usual
arrangement that means when i climb into
bed
i need to have the most comfortable
sleeping experience
possible and this is why i have bull and
branch sheets bullet and branches
signature sheets they feel soft and
light you're going to forget you're not
actually sleeping on a cloud they're
sustainably made for uncompromising
quality from field to factory
if you dream of comfortable sheets at a
price that are not going to keep you up
all night look no further than my
friends
over at bull and branch now sometimes
you buy sheets at like your local store
like ooh high thread count and then it
feels like you're sleeping under a tarp
and sometimes you buy sheets and you put
them through the wash a couple of times
and they start falling apart
these are the best sheets like you never
think about your sheets they are just
phenomenal these bowling brand sheets
bow and branch make the softest organic
sheets on the market they get better
with every single wash
comfort isn't their only standard they
use 100 sustainable raw materials
as the first fairtrade certified
manufacturer of linen you can feel as
good about your bowling brand sheets as
they feel against
your skin the signature hem sheets from
bowling branch are a bestseller for a
reason they're buttery soft lightweight
organic cotton and a classic sateen
weave for sheets that get softer
over time they are not too hot they are
not too cold they are the perfect
year-round sheets
for most sleepers experience the best
cheats you have ever felt at
bowlandbranch.com get 15
off your first set of sheets when you
use promo code shapiro i check out that
is bull and branch b-o-l-l
and branch dot com promo code shapiro go
check them out
right now for the special deal okay in
just a second we're gonna get to the
stuff that's actually happening in
american policy because it's being
unrolled
while the media are distracted with
whatever they are distracted with
namely everything but covering the biden
administration first gang got to tell
you
a daily wire membership it's the only
way you should be viewing our content if
you're not a member you're missing all
the best stuff right now using promo
code shapiro
you'll get 10 off any member plan you
choose what makes a membership so great
well
members get our articles had free access
to all of our live broadcasts show
library two full hours of the ben
shapiro show
and our always growing catalog of
content plus with our all access you'll
also receive two of the greatest of all
beverage vessels the leftist
tears tumbler yes you get all of that
plus 10
off when you use promo code shapiro so
stop depriving yourself come
join the fun visit www.dailywire.com use
promo code shapiro
become a member today and get that
special deal with that promo code
shapiro you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile as this
impeachment trial continues and
reaches its pre-ordained end because
it's very obvious which way
this is going joe biden continues to do
stuff that uh if if
donald trump did it and when he did it
was considered the worst stuff that has
ever happened so
let's just take a quick example the
biden administration has now asked for
resignations from every trump appointed
u.s attorney so remember that time that
trump did this with preet bharara
the new york ag or the new york ta
rather remember this
and it was like the biggest deal in the
world how dare he fire
the holdovers from the last
administration joe biden does it it's
like well isn't that nice
that's pretty great like it's totally
fine now here's the washington post
reporting that biden administration on
tuesday asked the remaining u.s
attorneys appointed by president trump
and confirmed by the senate to submit
their resignations
sparing only two federal prosecutors who
are conducting politically sensitive
probes
including of president biden's son
according to a doj news release and
officials
the resignations won't take effect
immediately the u.s attorneys were told
on a conference call they would be
allowed to stay until february 28th and
transition out people familiar with the
matter said
the move generated some criticism from
both sides of the political aisle
illinois's two democratic senators dick
durbin and tammy duckworth said in a
joint statement they were disappointed
they were not consulted
before the administration asked for the
resignation of u.s attorney
john louge whose office has been
pursuing a corruption case that has
raised questions about a powerful state
democratic lawmaker the senators say
while the president has the rights to
remove u.s attorneys there's precedent
for u.s attorneys in the northern
district of illinois to remain in office
to conclude sensitive investigations
some conservatives question the move's
timing which came just as impeachment
proceedings against
trump began ayan pryor a former justice
department spokesman in the trump
administration who now tracks moves in
the biden justice department noted that
when jeff sessions did this
everybody went crazy he said the biden
administration like the trump
administration before it has the
absolute right
to request resignations of incumbent u.s
attorneys what will be frustrating to
conservatives is that democrats pearl
clutching columnist and cable news
pundits
tried to spin it as a threat to
democracy when trump did it but now
we'll say all is well since it's biden
sending the pink slips that of course
is absolutely true meanwhile joe biden
continues
to use kovid as an excuse to do a bunch
of stupid crap
coveted relief does not need to be 1.9
trillion dollars nor does it need to
include things like 15
minimum wage hundreds of billions of
dollars dedicated to bailing out
blue states from their own crappy
pension deals it doesn't need to include
any of that stuff
it doesn't need to include billions more
in funding for schools that are not open
right that stuff does not need to happen
and yet joe biden is basically using
covet as an excuse to do all of this
because every crisis
is an opportunity the reality is we are
now in the home stretch when it comes to
covet the vaccinations are rolling out
americans can smell it americans can see
it okay americans can see that
everyone above the age of 65 who wants
to get the vaccine is going to have the
vaccine
and that's going to happen in fairly
short order and people who are below the
age of 65 are gonna have access to the
vaccine before the summer
and yet democrats continue to trot out
the idea that we are going to be in a
mode
of covet crisis all the way until
essentially thanksgiving
okay that's nuts that is crazy team
biden
is now trying to to drive this crisis to
epic proportions even though we are now
really clearly on the downslope of
coveted infections and of course deaths
and vaccinations
are taking place at record rates
according to the daily beast top members
of president joe biden's coveted
response team are warning internally the
us may not reach herd immunity until
thanksgiving or the start of winter
in an interview with cbs news this week
biden hinted at some of these concerns
saying it would be very difficult to
reach herd immunity much before the end
of the summer with the current daily
rate of approximately 1.3 million at
vaccine doses
other top officials working on the
federal government's covenant 19
response say they are uneasy about
vaccine supply long term and the impact
on herd immunity
okay so here's the thing about herd
immunity when it comes to vaccines okay
for the people who have already had the
vaccine
if you have say the first or vaccine you
have well over 90 immunity to the virus
just by rates
okay the second shot is providing you
something like 95
immunity what i mean by that is 95 shot
you that if you
if you are uh exposed to the virus you
don't get infected with it and if you
are
the the amount of damage that the virus
does to you is extraordinarily minimal
once you have these shots right by
percentages
then there is the question of people who
can't get the shot now here's the thing
when it comes to people who can't get
the shots we're really talking
essentially about a couple groups of
people
people who have a pre-existing condition
let's say that they have
uh some sort of uh leukemia or something
that it would endanger their life
to have the shot although this is being
given to people who have cancer right
now so i don't know the impact
on people who have leukemia the two
groups of people i know it is not safe
for at this point or has not been deemed
safe for are pregnant women and children
children are not vulnerable to the
disease kids are not experiencing
serious damage
from the disease as a general rule the
number of children who have died from
this disease
is i believe still in double digits in
the united states out of literally
tens of millions of people who have had
it when it comes to
pregnant women they are now doing trials
on whether pregnant women
will be able to have the vaccine beyond
that if the idea is we're supposed to
lock down the entire society forever
because there are a few vulnerable
people who cannot have the vaccine
that's not going to happen realistically
speaking it's not going to happen and
you're not going to be able to encourage
a bunch of young healthy people to have
the vaccine
if that comes along with the idea that
you still have to socially distance and
wear a mask until every single person in
the country
has had the vaccine then we're gonna
lock this thing down it is now february
it's it's february 10th we're going to
lock this thing down until next
november are you insane are you crazy
and yet that is what biden is pushing
and one of the reasons that team biden
is pushing all of this
instead of a transition back to regular
life which is what things are
i mean frankly that is what is already
happening in places like florida
to florida's credit and it should get
better and better as the vaccines roll
out
there is a there's another purpose here
okay the other purpose here is to
give an excuse for why you need to pour
money into the system why you need to
restructure systems of power
covet is an opportunity according to
people like joe biden means admitting
that here is joe biden
admitting that covet is an opportunity
as you know i've met
for a long time with my republican
colleagues
i've been exchanging correspondence with
them and telephone calls as well to see
if there's any way we can
follow up beyond where we are and
meeting with the
members of the house and the senate as
well and
uh i think we're i think we're in a
position to uh
to think big and move big and to move in
a direction that
can be not only get the economy back in
its feet but
we have to get people well before we get
people on their feet
okay so again we're just going to
continue to pour money into the system
and the more we can drive up the feeling
of crisis
the more we will be able to to use that
as an excuse to push forward
horrible horrible policy and by the way
this is horrible policy
okay that 19 that 1.9 trillion dollar
trillion dollar package that biden wants
to sign into law would include things
like a boost to the minimum wage
of 15 an hour by 2025. according to the
congressional budget office he's trying
to do this right now
via reconciliation it would cut
employment by 1.4 million jobs in 2025
and increase the budget deficit by 54
billion dollars over the next
10 years it would lift 900 000 americans
out of poverty it would put 1.4 million
americans
just that year out of a job and this is
considered good policy
by the democrats really well done here
all because of covid of course it really
has nothing to do with covid
at this point right what this really has
to do with a bunch of pre-existing
democratic priorities
and now they have an excuse to push that
stuff forward
and this is the the party of science
speaking here
it's uh it's pretty incredible okay
meanwhile the
the party of science continues to push
forward with a bunch of other
nonsense as well so jenn sackey
continues to make the case
that we are going to push toward opening
classrooms but then she was asked
specifically what do you mean by opening
classrooms you know when you say that
you want classrooms open in 100 days
what what exactly would your standard
for open b because is it open if you
have the classrooms open one day a week
what percentage of classrooms would have
to be open in order for you to deem the
classrooms open here is gen saki white
house press secretary explaining
his goal that he set is to have the
majority of schools so more than 50
percent
open uh by day 100 uh of his presidency
and that means uh some teaching in
classrooms so at least one day a week
hopefully it's more and obviously it is
as much as is safe in each school and
local district
when you say some teaching that's you
didn't use the same majority qualifier
there you just have to have some
teaching in school some teachers
in school not the majority of teachers
in school in the majority of classrooms
well teaching at least one day a week um
in the majority of schools by day 100
by day one in person teaching yes in
person teaching
one day a week in some schools 50 of
schools by day 100
and there are a couple of problems with
this one the data suggests that for
young kids the transmissibility is not
high
and there is no additional risk to
teachers of vis-a-vis the general public
from being in school with young children
okay that's that's problem number one
this is completely anti-science
like completely anti-science this is
they're just doing this at the best of
the teachers unions let's be perfectly
frank about this it is perfectly obvious
what is happening
this is about the teachers unions perry
stein of the washington post
she says the dc teachers union and aft
president randy weingarten have now
called on washington dc to close the
entire schools for cleaning
for at least 24 hours if one covet case
is detected
and kids who are grouped in cohorts must
quarantine for 14 days
if the case is detected okay that like
for everyone in the class has to
quarantine for 14 days
if a case is detected even if they test
negative
they don't have to quarantine for like
three and then test negative
okay this is crazy towns because it's
being run by the teachers unions it has
nothing to do with science okay so
that's problem number one it has nothing
to do with science
the science suggests it is open it is
safe to open schools
and particularly for kids who are under
the age of ten okay then
there is the second problem which is she
says that her goal here is that within
100 days
50 of the schools will be open with at
least one day of teaching a week
um one problem as per the usual
arrangement
the biden administration is setting
expectations so low that they are
already being achieved
okay just like they said we want 100
million doses out within the first
hundred days
and we were already doing a million
doses a day so they were essentially
lying about what was already happening
now they're doing the same thing with
school reopenings
here is the reality right now about 40
of schools in the united states are open
and then when it comes to the hybrid
model meaning some in classrooms i'm out
of classroom that's another 25
of schools so well over 60 of schools in
the united states already
meet the standard that she's saying 50
of schools should meet within 100 days
okay those are the current stats those
are the
the current stats that suggest we are
already there and yet there she is
saying look at look at the amazing
progress we are going to make so
basically i guess they're gonna have to
close more schools
in order to achieve this particular
purpose
they're actually going to have to close
schools in order to get back to 50
because we are over 60
last time i checked from the currently
available statistics
so this has nothing to do with science
this is all about alarmism and serving
the purposes of the teachers at unions
speaking of serving purposes that have
nothing to do with the interests of
students
so jen sackey was specifically asked
about trans girls competing in high
school sports
again the bible administration is just
getting more and more radical and we're
supposed to pretend they're moderate
because trump sure trump's been out of
office for a while here
sure he's not the president but trump
but trump is going to be the
the rallying call of the media and the
democratic party
for the rest of this administration
that's not rare obama did it with bush
now it's going to be but trump right so
it might be kind of a problem
that the federal government of the
united states is now essentially
mandating
that biological boys race against
biological girls and that biological
boys be allowed to go into locker rooms
with biological girls so long as they
say they are female
i mean that's kind of a problem just on
a logical level it also happens to
violate girls rights
girls do have a right not to have to
compete with boys girls do have a right
to be private from biological boys
that seems like the same people who
declared to right to privacy to kill a
baby in her womb say that it is not a
right to privacy for a 16 year old girl
not to want to be gazed upon by a
biological male in the locker room
the right to privacy just doesn't apply
there in any case jen sackey was asked
this question and
she reverts to type which is she's just
going to say bumper stickers
bumper stickers are the way that we
avoid all problems in this country right
now
does the president have a message for
local school officials on dealing with
these kind of disputes that are already
starting to arise
between uh you know trans
girls who are competing and cis girls
and a level playing field
particularly in high school sports i
would just say that the president's
belief
is that trans rights are human rights
and that's why he signed that executive
order
uh and in terms of the determinations by
universities and colleges i would
certainly defer to them
okay i i just have a question when she
says trans rights or human rights when
you don't define
that i mean it's just this is the way
that we avoid all political conversation
in this country
you ask should this person does this
person actually have the right to go
into like
a girl's locker room and you just say
trans rates are human rights you can
fill in that that
trans with literally anything you just
say anything right so you say for
example
okay does a does a gay couple have a
right to be married inside a traditional
church do they have that right
not should the church marry them on a
moral level i think every church has the
ability to make that decision for
themselves there's plenty of biblical
scriptural precedent for churches not
participating in activities they believe
to be sinful
and by the way that is the precedent of
american history but if you're a
democrat
all you have to do is say something like
gay rights or human rights because once
you say our human rights
then that ends the argument there's no
discussion to be had about balancing
people's rights the rights of freedom of
religion or the right to
to a supposed right to respect which
doesn't actually exist
right the the it is very easy to avoid
all conversation
about the complexities and trade-offs of
particular policy when you just say
something like blank rights are human
rights
thank you for that bumper sticker slogan
biden administration as you pursue
unprecedentedly radical policy
speaking of unprinted unprecedentedly
radical policy joe biden has now signed
52 executive orders and actions in his
first 20 days in office
according to ian hayworth over at the
daily wire by
by february 1st biden had signed an
unprecedented 42 executive orders in
just the first few days of his
administration
those included executive orders which
look to expand socialized medicine
provide taxpayer funding for foreign
abortions destroy american energy jobs
rejoin meaningless and counterproductive
international agreements and
organizations
further the promotion of a historical
mischaracterizations of the united
states and call for transgender rights
in school sports to name a few
since the beginning of february biden
has signed an additional nine executive
orders
and actions he continues to add to the
list his running tally is currently at
executive wars and actions after 20 days
in office
so this is all exciting exciting stuff
but but believe me it's all moderation
guys it is
all moderation it is fine because joe
biden is doing it he can fire
every single person who is appointed to
a u.s attorney's office
just the way trump did and trump was a
radical trying to destroy the american
trying to destroy the american way of
life and joe biden is moderate joe biden
can sign more executive orders than all
prior presidents
of the last 40 years combined in his
first month
and that's okay because after all joe
biden is a moderate if you just keep
chanting joe biden is moderate it's like
beetlejuice if you say it three times he
appears
if you say joe biden is a moderate
trebiden appears stumbles around a
little while
says an incomprehensible sentence and
then falls over while signing an
executive order
and it's all fine it's all fine because
this is all moderate policy right like
for example it's super moderate policy
that the biden administration has just
dropped
a trump proposal to track chinese
influence in american schools
according to chuck ross reporting over
at the daily caller
the biden administration quietly
withdrew a rule proposed by the trump
administration
that would have required american
schools and universities to disclose
their partnerships with confucius
institutes
which some u.s officials allege are
front groups for chinese communist party
propaganda
the trump administration submitted a
proposed rule to the department of
homeland security on december 31 2020 it
was entitled
establishing requirement for student and
exchange visitor program certified
schools to disclose agreements with
confucius institutes and classrooms in
other words we didn't want
the chinese government basically putting
propaganda agents
inside u.s schools around 500 k-12
schools and 65 colleges in the us
have partnerships with the confucius
institute u.s center
which is a us-based affiliate of the
beijing-based confucius institute
headquarters
that institute is affiliated with the
chinese ministry of education
the daily caller has previously reported
that many of the directors are members
of the ccp
the trump era proposal was withdrawn
from consideration january 26th
there's no information as to why this
happened the website does say that at
any point in the review process for a
proposed rule an agency can withdraw the
rule from review and choose not to move
forward with it or to resubmit it after
further consideration
first of all republicans in congress
should immediately immediately take this
up as a piece of legislation and try to
push democrats to vote up or down on it
because the amount of cow towing that's
about to happen to the chinese
government
is astonishing it is large-scale and
astonishing
secretary of state mike pompeo said on
august 13th the confucius institute was
quote an entity controlled by the prc
that advances beijing's global
propaganda and malign influence campaign
on us campuses and k-12
classrooms but uh biden is now walking
back that rule
which is really excellent policy i mean
really
totally moderate everything is moderate
speaking of moderate the
omb nominee so joe biden is nominating
to the office of management and budget
head
nera tanzan neurotenant has a long
history of
really sort of bizarre and radical
behavior on twitter she spent a lot of
time ripping people personally on
twitter
but not only that there's a big scandal
for for near attendance she used to be
the center for american progress
in which she overtly said the name of a
woman who had
apparently anonymously reported sexual
harassment she said it in a meeting
and people at the at the company were
like what are you doing right now
senior attendant not particularly well
liked on either side of the aisle that's
who he's decided to put forward for omb
senator james lankford of oklahoma goes
after omb nominee yesterday in her
hearing
one statement that you made about uh
people that have the personal religious
convictions about contraception like
little sisters the poor and others
called them a successful political
cudgel
helping isolate extreme advocates from
the mainstream
that one seems to cross a different line
for me the context didn't seem to be
about
people that use religion as a cudgel it
seemed to be that
the personal beliefs of those
individuals became the cudgel
that's the part that threw me in that
okay well that's the source of the
neurotension routinely put out there no
again people are entitled to tweet
whatever they want but can we stop
pretending that this is an
administration staffed by moderates
joe biden was not immoderate joe biden
is not a moderate
by personal sort of temperament he may
be more moderate because he is a
bloviating blowhard who likes to talk a
lot
but that doesn't mean that he is
actually somebody who crosses the aisle
on a regular basis he's a hard-nosed
partisan he's been a hard-nosed partisan
since he participated in the destruction
of robert bork and clarence thomas
i mean there's nothing new here with joe
biden the the attempt to paint him as a
moderate was a pure campaign ploy
so they could pretend there was going to
be a return to normalcy well i guess
there is a return to normalcy it's just
the radicalism of the democratic party
shielded by the media that's the normal
that was always going to be the normal
and it continues a pace even while the
media
focused their attention on an
impeachment trial that is going
absolutely nowhere
alrighty we'll be back here today with
an additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael
knowles show he's going to be discussing
a 116 year old french nun
who beat covid you can hear more details
about that particular story on michael's
show that is available right now i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam scievents
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
if you want to cut through the madness
of our politics and culture and know
what's
really going on and what it really means
head on over to the michael knowles show
where we can all bask in the simple joys
of being right
see you there